believe it or not and I know a lot of
people misunderstand the current Google
but the Google I joined hmm Larry and
Sergey would always tell us it's not
about the money if you manage to solve a
big problem that affects the lives of a
billion people or more
you're bound to make money yeah you know
Larry used to call it the toothbrush
test if if you managed to invent the
next toothbrush and people use it twice
a day they're probably gonna pay you
something mm-hmm right but the focus was
can I actually solve that problem
capitalism took that away so the first
thing we start with is the business plan
how much is there money is there in it
you know how much can we reduce our cost
how much can we increase our revenue we
forgot and the difference between you
solving the problem and making a very
good living like a big Corp approach for
example and just squeezing every cent
out of it is that you're gonna get 999
million dollars more when all you need
is a $20 t-shirt what a waste of life
what a waste of life by the way I'm in
no way I'm in no way saying don't be
filthy rich don't be a hyper influential
don't be extremely powerful I'm
absolutely saying that the biggest
problem we have of our world today is
that the people who chase rich richness
you know wealth Fame and power are not
the best of us if the best of us become
rich become famous become powerful
become influential we would change the
world
so I actually tell people it's your
absolute duty if you're a good person
to become as effective as impactful as
you can in this world yes but when
you're doing it do it out of positivity
don't do it with your unhappiness your
stress as the tax to pay on the path
don't do it from a egotistical
hedonistic greedy perspective do it from
bringing utility to civilization making
it a better place for forever